el barrio de sheikh jarrah en jerusalén
este fue el punto de partida del
conflicto el detonante fueron las
tensiones ante el posible desalojo al
que se enfrentaban docenas de familias
palestinas una organización de colonos
judíos reclaman las tierras como propias
el máximo tribunal israelí tenía
previsto anunciar su decisión el 10 de
mayo pero pospuso su fallo añadiendo más
tensión que derivó en fuertes
enfrentamientos en medio de los restos
del ramadán en la mezquita de al-aqsa la
policía israelí se enfrentó a la
multitud con gases lacrimógenos y balas
de goma las fuerzas israelíes
irrumpieron en la explanada de las
mezquitas por la fuerza hiriendo a
cientos de palestinos unos incidentes
que se suscitaron la condena de la
comunidad musulmana mientras el
movimiento islamista hamás comenzó a
lanzar cohetes desde gaza en represalia
por lo que consideró crímenes y
agresiones de israel hacia los árabes de
jerusalén la respuesta israelí no se
hizo esperar bajo la llamada operación
guardián de los muros lanzó decenas de
ataques aéreos sobre gaza mientras hamas
e israel intercambiaban bombardeos
l'aire la violencia se extendieron a las
calles de la ciudad de flix
y la comunidad internacional presionó
para poner fin a las hostilidades con el
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
llevando a cabo reuniones de emergencia
pero cuyas resoluciones serán bloqueadas
por eeuu el presidente joe biden reiteró
su pedido a israel para desescalar el
conflicto que este viernes finalizó con
un cese al fuego bilateral acordado con
la mediación de egipto en 11 días jamás
disparó más de 4000 cohetes contra
israel la mayoría interceptados por el
sistema de defensa cúpula de hierro los
proyectiles que atravesaron mataron a 12
personas en gaza- la destrucción y la
violencia fue mucho mayor
los bombardeos derribaron edificios
escuelas hospitales matando a más de 230
personas entre ellas 65 niños provocando
el desplazamiento interno de más de
70.000 palestinos